8 heures ils sont six ans à s'installer
dans l'amphithéâtre beaucoup n'ont
aucune idée de ce qui les attend cette
semaine ce qu'ils savent très bien par
contre c'est pourquoi ils sont là ouart
qui n'est plus tard sages-femmes si
possible mais ça n'est christianiste
peut-être dentiste psychiatre mais pour
ça il faudra déjà réussir le concours de
première année autant s'y préparer le
plus tôt possible et aussitôt arrivés ou
presque ça commence par un cours de
chimie de noyaux son isotope quand ils
ont le même numéro atomique c'est à dire
le même nombre de protons dans le rôle
du professeur mills n étudiante en 3e
année et membre du ted le tutorat en
santé de dijon le thème franchement je
trouve qu'il fait indispensable et du
coup je me suis dit que on m'avait des
donc moi aussi j'allais aider les autres
j'aime bien transmettre donc c'est
l'occasion de le faire comme milices et
nick sont 65 prêt à conseiller soutenir
les nouveaux arrivants les faire
travailler aussi avec tous les lundis
les fameuses coll entre autres on
également parce qu'on appelle les
séances tutorat ça c'est des petits
cours contre à chaque semaine au 6 qui
ont pour but de revoir une petite notion
d'un course et deux fois dans l'année
donc une fois par semestre
on fera ce qu'on appelle un concours
blanc un programme d'accompagnement
complet est un vrai plus pour espérer
passer en deuxième année
ça permet aux étudiants déjà d'avoir un
environnement plus cocooning se diraient
ils sont pris en charge par des
étudiants qui sont passés par là qu'ils
ont vécu les mêmes expériences et dons
qui peuvent être encadrée de façon plus
personnalisée et plus participative et
les tuteurs dijonnais ont pensé à toutes
les premières années ont même eu droit à
un cours de relaxation apprendre à gérer
son stress pas de doute ça sera utile